definitely appears to be a coordinated
attack on energy infrastructure
how about the forecast everything will
be impacted
leading to mass panic hoarding than
violence
last Light is about Echo terrorist
attack on the oil supply something's
wrong with the oil Andy whatever you can
do to fix this me and the ultrasound
team are at your disposal we'll get to
the bottom of it the series stars
Matthew Fox and let me just say how
thrilling it is to be a part of Matthew
Fox's return to television I am playing
Andy Yates he's a petrochemist trying to
do preliminary investigation of what's
going on with the oil I need you to do a
full run down what exactly are we
looking for here not sure our main
family are separated in different
countries at the time of the attack so
it's about their fight to get back to
each other throughout this series we are
ducking into each one of these stories
as the crisis unfolds so for each of
them it's escalated you knew we were in
danger you didn't think you needed to
tell me about that
we are very much ripped from the
headlines it's one of the reasons
Muslims of that it was really important
to have real locations no stage sets I
wanted the audience to feel that this
was happening to them traveling to the
Middle East and all the other places it
gives us a sense of where things are
starting but that it's going global
shooting last Light On Location Prague
it has an incredibly exciting
action-packed feel of the sort of genre
that we're shooting this is a story with
that backdrop creating a crisis but it's
really about this family trying to find
their way back to each other promise me
that you're gonna find my family
it's really simple the clock is ticking
we know that if we don't get off our
dependency on oil we're going to run out
of time
I guess
[Applause]
I don't really know many young people
who aren't in some way invested in the
climate crisis and people aren't
listening to young people when they talk
about it something needs to be done now
the Sears in particular in shows the
possible consequences if we don't find a
way to change our Behavior it's a big
adventure and I'm looking forward to the
audience getting an opportunity to
experience that Adventure